election interference former president
Donald Trump has been indicted and
arraigned for interfering with the 2020
election the alleged facts of this
conspiracy are astounding now we've
covered the legality of the crimes
alleged but it's worth exploring the
facts of the crimes as well a prosecutor
Jack Smith lays out a story that is as
yet unproven in court but is the most
comprehensive look at the conspiracy to
overturn and subvert the 2020 election
to date now this story takes place in
two months between November 14th 2020
and Joe Biden's swearing-in ceremony on
January 20th 2021. the indictment says
that the conspiracy started 11 days
after the general election now during
that time we got the worst gay of
criminals to work with Donald Trump
since Harry and Marvin Home Alone 2.
this cast of characters is enumerated in
paragraph 8 starting with co-conspirator
1 an attorney who was willing to spread
knowingly false claims and pursue
strategies that defendants 2020
re-election campaign attorneys would not
you guessed it give it up for America's
mayor Rudy Giuliani a co-conspirator 2
an attorney who devised and attempted to
implement his strategy to Leverage The
vice president's ceremonial role
overseeing the certification proceeding
to obstruct the certification of the
presidential election that is top
Republican legal mind John Eastman
co-conspirator 3 an attorney whose
unfounded claims of election fraud the
defendant privately acknowledged two
others sounded crazy nonetheless the
defendant embraced and publicly
Amplified co-conspirator 3's
disinformation you know her from
shipwrecks of old give it up for Sydney
the Kraken Powell then there's
co-conspirator 4 a justice department
official who worked on civil matters and
who with the defendant attempted to use
the justice department to open sham
election crime investigations and
influence state legislatures with
knowingly false claims of election fraud
he was a lawyer in the environment and
Natural Resources Division until Trump
offered to make him acting attorney
general yes this is Assistant Attorney
General Jeffrey we'll call you when
there's an oil spill clerk then there's
co-conspirator 5 an attorney who
assisted in devising and attempting to
implement a plan to submit fraudulent
slates of presidential electors to
obstruct the certification proceedings
this is a pellet lawyer and humorous
name Haver kind of cheese bro then there
is finally co-conspirator 6 a political
consultant who helped Implement a plan
to submit fraudulent slates of
presidential electors to obstruct the
certification proceeding co-conspirator
6 appears to be Boris Epstein one of
Trump's advisors though this has yet to
be confirmed Epstein is best known for
writing Trump's controversial Holocaust
Remembrance Day speech in which he
admitted any mention of Jewish people
yeah this has not been a great day for
the legal profession because all six of
the co-conspirators May in fact be
lawyers these six co-conspirators could
be indicted in the coming weeks or
months or they could be government
Witnesses no one knows at the moment and
it may be up to them but the bottom line
is Trump worked with this cast of
co-conspirators to subvert the Electoral
count act and stop Congress from
certifying the election the ECA governs
the process of casting and Counting
Electoral College votes for President
and Vice President and the statute sets
forth the timeline for states to appoint
presidential elections in November and
for electors to cast their votes in
December and describes the process that
Congress should follow when it counts
the the state's electoral votes in
January these days each state casts
electoral votes based on their State's
popular vote and then sends their
electoral votes along with the state
executive certification that they were
the state's legitimate electors to
Congress to be counted at an official
proceeding now the indictment says that
Trump and his cronies organize quote
fraudulent slates of electors in seven
targeted States Arizona Georgia Michigan
Nevada New Mexico Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin attempting to mimic the
procedure that the legitimate electors
were supposed to follow under the
Constitution and other federal and state
laws the conspirators caused these fake
electors to quote meet on the day
appointed by federal law on which
legitimate electors were to gather and
cast their votes cast fraudulent votes
for the defendant and signed
certificates falsely representing that
they were legitimate electors one day
before Trump was indicted in D.C 16 of
these fraudulent electors were indicted
in Michigan for participating in this
scheme and Trump also attempted to use
the power and authority of the justice
department to launch a sham criminal
investigation into voter fraud that
didn't occur this apparently include
sending a letter outlining false claims
that the doj discovered massive election
irregularities and recommending that
these states call a special legislative
session to determine quote who won the
most legal votes and consider appointing
a new slate of electors now some of the
most troubling allegations involved
Jeffrey Clark the Environmental Lawyer
at the doj who Trump wanted to appoint
as attorney general in the waning weeks
of his term Clark met secretly with
Trump on December 22nd failing to inform
his superiors of the meeting which is of
course doj protocol now it's obvious why
he didn't tell them Trump and his allies
allegedly tried to get acting Attorney
General Jeffrey Rosen to sign a letter
that made quote knowingly false claims
of election fraud to officials in the
targeted States through a formal letter
under the acting attorney general's
signature thus giving the defendants
lies the backing of the federal
government and attempting to improperly
influence the target states to replace
legitimate Biden electors with
defendants now apparently Rosen wanted
nothing to do with this and on December
26 he told Clark not to meet with Trump
again without notice Clark said the
meeting was an accident and he would
abide by rosen's directive but the next
morning he had a three-minute phone call
with Trump and afterwards Trump met with
Rosen and the acting Deputy attorney
general and told them that he was
considering replacing Rosen with Clark
people tell me Jeffrey Clark is great I
should put him in when Rosen refused to
say the election was corrupt Trump told
him to quote just say that the election
was corrupt and leave the rest to me and
the Republican congressman and of course
people are pointing to this quote as
evidence that Trump actually knew that
the election was not fraudulent on
December 28th Clark circulated the
letter Trump wanted Rosen to send and
it's important to note here how insane
it is that Jeff Clark who was still
officially assigned to the environmental
Department was suddenly running point on
Trump's Maneuvers with the doj he was
sending his boss Jeff Rosen the same
letter that Rosen had already refused to
sign a clerk proposed sending versions
of this to Battleground states that
Biden won and here's the claims made in
that letter which the government says
are false the justice department had
quote identified significant concerns
that may have impacted the outcome of
the election in multiple States the
justice department believed that in
Georgia and other states two valid
slates of electors had gathered at the
proper location on December 14th and
that both sets of ballots had been
transmitted to Congress that is
co-conspirator 4 Jeff Clark's letter
sought to advance the defendant's
fraudulent electoral plan by using the
authority of the justice department to
falsely present the fraudulent electors
as a valid alternative to the legitimate
electors the justice department urged
the state legislature to convene a
special legislative session to create
the opportunity to among other things
choose the fraudulent electors over the
legitimate electors but Rosen rebuffed
Clark again and told him not to engage
with Trump on New Year's Eve Trump
summoned Rosen and other doj lawyers and
told them he might have to change
leadership at the doj now the justice
department traditionally operates fairly
independently from the White House our
presidents aren't supposed to order the
Attorney General to make legal decisions
but here was Trump insisting that they
send the letter and on January 2nd Clark
continued his insubordination by asking
his boss and others to sign the letter
Trump wanted to send he told them that
Trump was considering firing Rosen and
replacing him with Clark but that he
declined the job if frozen would just
cave and send the letter with false
fraud allegations on January 3rd Clark
revised the fraud letter changing his
language about concerns to a stronger
false claim that quote as of today there
is evidence of significant
irregularities that may have impacted
the outcome of the election in multiple
States now that was apparently enough
for Trump to give him the acting
Attorney General job because the two met
and Clark accepted the job so Clark
spent all day scheming with Trump and
testing the limits of the new power now
apparently quote a deputy White House
counsel tried to dissuade Clark from
assuming the role of acting attorney
general the deputy White House Council
reiterated to co-conspirator 4 Jeff
Clark that there had not been outcome
determined fraud in the election and
that if the defendant remained in office
nonetheless there would be quote riots
in every major city in the United States
Jeff Clark responded quote well Deputy
White House counsel that's why there's
an Insurrection act Clark apparently
then called his boss and told him that
he was now the acting attorney general
Rosen responded that he would not accept
being fired by a subordinate and
immediately scared scheduled a meeting
with the defendant for that evening but
there was apparently a very strong Push
by the justice department attorneys to
stop Trump and Clark from implicating
the doj and overturning a valid election
in fact Trump only gave up on his plan
to install Clark as a g after quote he
was told that it would result in Mass
resignations at the justice department
and of his own White House Council of
course Mass resignations are not
something that happened every day and if
the justice department lawyers resigned
on mass then it would probably have
blown the whistle on what the
conspirators were trying to do Jeffrey
Clark drafted a letter to Georgia saying
quote the Department of Justice is
investigating various irregularities in
the 2020 election for President of the
United States the department will update
you as we're able on investigatory
progress but at this time we have
identified significant concerns that may
have impacted the outcome of the
election in multiple States including
the state of Georgia now this was false
the doj plays no role in certifying the
winner of the presidential election
State investigations and audits
confirmed that Biden won the state in
every Court which considered the issue
ruled against Trump but the indictment
has a whole section on Trump's efforts
to overturn the Georgia election results
now this section of the indictment is
pretty funny because it actually
describes two different methods of
attack Trump took one with Sydney Powell
and the other with Rudy Giuliani now the
Powell method only takes up one
paragraph because her lawsuit was
dismissed so quickly and obviously but
it has some great details on November
16th Trump's quote executive assistant
sent Powell and others a document
containing bullet points critical of a
certain voting machine company writing
uh see attached please include as is or
almost as is in lawsuit co-conspirator 3
City Powell responded nine minutes later
writing quote it must go in all suits in
Georgia and Pennsylvania immediately
with a fraud claim that requires the
entire election to be set aside in those
States and machines impounded for
non-partisan professional inspection now
I can only assume that this was a reply
all given the abundance of all caps but
the indictment does not say nine days
later pal filed a lawsuit quote against
the governor of Georgia falsely alleging
massive election fraud accomplished
through the voting machine company
companies election software and Hardware
in the next chunk of the paragraph We
have a Vindication Trump's ability to
actually assess legal issues quote
before the lawsuit was even filed the
defendant retweeted a post-promoting it
the defendant did this despite the fact
that when he had discussed
co-conspirator 3's far-fetched public
claims regarding the voting machine
company in private with advisors the
defendant had conceded that they were
unsupported and that co-conspirator 3
sounded quote crazy co-conspirator 3's
Georgia lawsuit was dismissed on
December 7th it's actually kind of
refreshing to hear Trump be right on the
money for once Sydney Powell is in fact
crazy but this may be a broken clock
type situation but in the next paragraph
though the doj goes on to the much more
worrisome moves by Trump and Rudy
Giuliani to pressure Georgia Secretary
of State Brad raffensberger into
overturning the state's election results
basically Trump and Giuliani and
raffensberger go back and forth with
raffensberger and other Georgia
officials calmly and repeatedly telling
Trump that there were neither dead nor
illegitimate voters in large numbers in
Georgia eventually this defeatist
attitude infected Trump's own team quote
as early as mid-november for instance
the senior campaign advisor had informed
Trump that his claims of a large number
of dead voters in Georgia were untrue
with respect to the persistent false
claim regarding State Farm Arena on
December 8th the senior campaign advisor
wrote in an email when our research and
campaign legal team can't back up any of
the claims made by our Elite Strike
Force legal team you can see why we're o
and 32 in our cases I'll obviously
hustle to help on all fronts but it's
tough to own any of this when it's all
just conspiracy beamed down from the
mothership yes believe it or not the
Trump Camp did actually refer to this
group of some of the worst lawyers who
have ever practiced in America as the
elite Strike Force legal team
now as you can probably tell Trump is
probably going to need a really good
lawyer based on these facts but if you
need a great lawyer my firm the eagle
team can help if you've had an injury or
death in the family suffered a data
breach or were involved in a car crash
we can represent you or help find the
right attorney who can't just click on
the link in the description for a free
consultation with my team because you
don't just need a legal team you need
the eagle team the link is down below
but of course all the stuff is a little
silly and easy to make fun of now but at
the time Giuliani and Trump singled out
and harassed individual election
staffers quote at the hearing before the
Georgia House of Representatives
government Affairs committee Giuliani
played the State Farm Arena video again
and falsely claimed that it showed voter
fraud right in front of people's eyes
and was the tip of the iceberg then he
cited two election workers by name
basically accusing them of quite
obviously surreptitiously passing around
USB ports as if they are vials of heroin
or cocaine these workers were Shane moss
and Ruby Freeman who subsequently
received numerous death threats Shane
Moss testified before the January six
committee about what actually happened
Mr Giuliani accused you and your mother
of passing some sort of USB drive to
each other
what was your mom actually handing you
on that video
a gingerman and in other testimony Ruby
Freeman described how unsafe Giuliani
and Trump's actions made her feel in her
own Community now I won't even introduce
my self by my name anymore I get nervous
when I have to give my name for food
orders around the week of January 6th
the FBI informed me that I needed to
leave my home for safety understood how
long did you stay out did you you know
remain outside of your home I I stayed
away from my home for approximately two
months and Trump continued to drag
Freeman and Moss's names through the mud
in his now Infamous perfect call with
Brad raffensberger having to do with the
Ruby Freeman that's she's a vote scammer
a professional vote scammer and Hustler
and later in the call Trump of course
asked rothensberger to find 11 780 votes
for him I just want to find
uh 11 780
votes which is one more that we have
because we won the state similarly on
December 7th despite still having
established no fraud in Michigan
co-conspirator 1 sent a text intended
for the Michigan Senate Majority Leader
quote so I need you to pass a joint
resolution from the Michigan legislature
that states that the election is in
dispute there's an ongoing investigation
by the legislature and the electors sent
by Governor Whitmer are not the official
electors of the state of Michigan and do
not fall within the safe harbor deadline
of December 8th under Michigan law now
I'd be curious to hear why the
indictment says that Giuliani intended
that text to be sent to the Michigan
Senate Majority Leader did he send that
to someone close to the majority leader
who would then pass along the message or
did he actually send that to someone who
wasn't connected at all who then turned
it over to the FBI then hopefully we'll
get an answer to that question anyway
quote on December 14th the Michigan
house speaker and Michigan Senate
Majority Leader announced that contrary
to the defendant's request they would
not decertify the legitimate election
results or electors in Michigan now
about a month after trying to dupe State
electoral officials Trump and his man
very gang a quote developed a new plan
to Marshal individuals who would have
served as the defendant's electors had
he won the popular vote in seven
targeted States Arizona Georgia Michigan
Nevada New Mexico Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin and cause those individuals to
make and send to the vice president in
Congress false certifications that they
were legitimate electors under the plan
the submission of these fraudulent
slates would create a fake controversy
at the certification proceeding and
position the vice president presiding on
January 6 as president of the Senate to
supplant legitimate electors with the
defendant's fake electors and certify
the defendant as president paragraph 58
has a fun account of how this would have
gone down as recalled by an Arizona
attorney invited to be a fake elector
the next day on December 8th Kenneth
chisbro called the Arizona attorney on
Boris Epstein's list in an email after
the call the Arizona attorney recounted
his conversation with cheese bro as
follows I just talked to the gentleman
who did that memo Ken she's bro his idea
is basically that all of us have our
electors send in their votes even though
the votes aren't legal under federal law
because they're not signed by the
governor so that members of Congress can
fight about whether they should be
counted on January 6th they could
potentially argue that they're not bound
by the federal law because they're
Congress and make the law et cetera kind
of wild slash creative I'm happy to
discuss my comment to him was that I
guess there's no harm in it legally at
least I we would just be sending in fake
electoral votes to Pence so that someone
in Congress can make an objection when
they start counting votes and start
arguing that the fake votes should be
counted a couple little fun editorials
by this attorney that I want to point
out first he points out that the fake
collectors would be illegal under
federal law then the lawyer pivots to
conclude that the scheme would result in
Congressional debate that legal at least
Would Do no harm there's no harm in it
legally at least is doing a lot of heavy
lifting like Schwarzenegger levels of
lifting like Joan Rivers levels of
lifting and secondly wild slash creative
is probably how you want to describe an
ugly drawing that your friend's kid made
not really a plan to overturn the
presidential election but if you
encounter a legal theory that is wild
slash creative you should probably
travel expeditiously in the other
direction now the other people familiar
with Trump's plan namely his
co-conspirators absolutely refused to
stand by it when push came to shove
quote on December 13th the defendant
asked the senior campaign advisor for an
update on what was going on with the
elector plan and directed him to put out
a statement on electors when the senior
campaign advisor related those
developments in text messages to the
deputy campaign manager a senior advisor
to the defendant and a campaign staffer
the deputy campaign manager responded
here's the thing the way this is morphed
it's a crazy plan so I don't know who
wants to put their name on it and it
continues the senior advisor wrote
certifying illegal votes in turn the
participants in the group text message
refused to have a statement regarding
electors attributed to their names
because none of them could stand by it
now the indictment also alleges that
Trump put extreme pressure on Mike Pence
including putting a damper on what I can
only assume was a very Bland Christmas
dinner on Christmas Day Pence called
Trump to wish him a Merry Christmas but
Trump steered the conversation to the
election leading Pence to tell him you
know I don't think I have authority to
change the outcome
and here the indictment cites to the
vice president's contemporaneous notes
to allege that Trump told Pence that the
doj was Finding major infractions and
that happened on December 29th long
after multiple doj officials told Trump
that there was actually no fraud on
January 1st 2021 Trump allegedly berated
Pence for refusing to go along with his
proposal in response the defendant told
the vice president you're too honest
then on January 4th Trump met with Pence
one of the co-conspirators the vice
president's chief of staff and the vice
president's Council to convince Pence
that he should reject Joe Biden's
electoral votes or resend them back to
the States during the meeting as
reflected in the vice president's
contemporaneous notes the defendant made
knowingly false claims of election fraud
including bottom line won every state by
hundreds of thousands of votes and we
won every state side note Mike Pence is
now selling merch that says too honest
to capitalize on this historic moment
Trump met with Pence again on January
5th to convince him to overturn the
election but when Pence refused Trump
quote grew frustrated and told the vice
president that the defendant would have
to publicly criticize him but quote upon
learning this the vice president's chief
of staff was concerned for the vice
president's safety and alerted the head
of the vice president's Secret Service
detail later that day Trump tweeted that
quote the vice president and I are in
total agreement that the vice president
has the power to act as an aside this is
probably important because it shows that
Trump wasn't just lying about whether he
believed he won the election as far as
we know Pence never agreed with Trump
that the vice president had the legal
authority to do what Trump wanted him to
do and the indictment says that Trump
lied about Pence's intentions which
theoretically moved the conspiracy
forward and on January 6 Trump tweeted
about Pence repeatedly staffers from
Senator Ron Johnson's office sent the
fraudulent certificates to Pence's
office but a pet staffer refused to
accept them the indictment says Trump
exploited the violence of the capital to
pressure Pence when staffers left him
alone in the dining room he tweeted that
quote Mike Pence didn't have the courage
to do what should have been done to
protect our country and just one minute
later the Secret Service had to evacuate
the vice president to a secure location
they took Pence to a place where he
could never be found presumably a room
with a woman in it but quote upon
learning this the vice president's chief
of staff was concerned for the vice
president's safety and alerted the head
of the vice president's Secret Service
detail while Mike Pence was hiding from
writers Trump took this opportunity to
pressure lawmakers into delaying the
certification and Trump had Giuliani
call five senators and a representative
and one of the calls co-conspirator one
left a voicemail intended for United
States Senator that said we need you our
Republican friends to try to just slow
it down so we can get these legislatures
to get more information to you and I
know they're reconvening at eight
tonight but the only strategy we can
follow is to object to numerous States
and raise issues so that we get
ourselves into tomorrow ideally until
the end of tomorrow and later that night
Giuliani claimed that illegal immigrants
had voted in substantial numbers in
Arizona and that Georgia gave you a
number in which 65 000 people who were
underage voted now Trump supporters
insist that Trump really believed the
election was stolen and we covered the
implications of Trump's mental state in
the prior video that we did on this and
well I suppose anything is possible it's
hard hard to believe when he was being
rebuffed so strongly by the justice
department and so many other people at
the same time especially because lawyers
and advisors kept telling Trump that he
lost one Deputy White House counsel
apparently said quote there is no world
there is no option in which you do not
leave the White House on January 20th
and it is alleged that Trump
acknowledged privately that he lost for
example after the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff urged Trump to not take
action on a national security issue
Trump agreed saying quote yeah you're
right it's too late for us we're going
to give that to the next guy that was on
January 3rd just three days before the
Trump inspired voters came to the
Capitol and interrupted the
certification and the New York Times
reports that the special Counsel had
access to previously unseen internal
Memo from the 2020 Trump campaign
describing in detail the plot by Donald
Trump and his lawyers to subvert the
election results in Six States the memo
was written by Ken chisbro and it
describes a three-pronged plan to
prevent Congress from certifying Joe
Biden's Victory on January 6 2020. the
memo was sent to a Wisconsin lawyer
James R troopas the lead attorney for
the Trump campaign in Wisconsin who
oversaw the fake elector scheme in his
State quote jubis filed a lawsuit in
December 2020 asking the Wisconsin
Supreme Court to throw out hundreds of
thousands of absentee ballots saying
they violated voting requirements the
court ultimately rejected the lawsuit
the cheeseburger wrote to troopa's
saying quote it seems feasible the Trump
campaign could subvert Biden's Victory
his plan would quote Force the members
of Congress the media and the American
people to focus on the substantive
evidence of illegal election and
Counting activities in the six contested
States provided three things happen and
according to cheese bro's plan quote
Republican electors in all Six States
Arizona Georgia Michigan Nevada
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin would meet
and cast votes for Trump on the 14th of
December 2020 the deadline for electors
to send their votes to Congress for
certification in January attorneys in
each of the Six States would
simultaneously file lawsuits that would
lead to either a trump Victory or a
Biden loss which would be pending on the
6th of January the certification date
and then finally on the day the Congress
meets to certify the elector's votes uh
quote Pence presiding over the joint
session takes the position position that
it is his constitutional power and duty
alone as president of the Senate to both
open and count the votes and that
anything in the Electoral count acts to
the contrary is unconstitutional now
before Donald Trump Goes to Jail I'm
sure he'd love to have one last
home-cooked meal which he can do with
today's sponsor because with hellofresh
you can make it exactly how you want
even cooked extremely well done and
slathered in ketchup you know you do you
but fall is right around the corner and
hellofresh is here to help you plan for
a busy season ahead with tasty dishes
delivered to your door simply choose the
recipes and pick your delivery date and
then lay back and enjoy the last days of
summer knowing that dinner is covered
hellofresh keeps your taste buds on
their toes with 40 Chef crafted recipes
that you can select from every week from
family friendly to fit and wholesome
you'll always find something new and
exciting to try and love hellofresh is a
great way to eat delicious fresh food
while still being healthy now I'm a
do-it-yourself person and I have to say
I was initially pretty skeptical about
hellofresh I'm a pretty good cook so I
didn't think that I needed to help but I
actually loved it even for an
experienced cook hellofresh delivers new
ingredients and recipes that I would
never try on my own and of course
everything was delivered straight to my
door so I didn't have to do any shopping
the produce actually gets to you faster
than grocery store so it arrives at Peak
freshness and flavor and it's also super
easy to save time hellofresh cuts out
the meal planning and prep so the
recipes only take 20 to 30 minutes to
cook literally less time to cook than it
would normally take to do the shopping
and hellofresh is at least 25 cheaper
than takeout so if you'd like to try
hellofresh go to hellofresh.com and use
the code 50 legal eagle at checkout for
50 off plus free shipping yes you can
actually get 50 off plus free shipping
by clicking on the link that's on screen
right now or down in the description so
click on the link below and use the code
50 legal eagle at checkout after that
click on this link over here for more
legal eagle or I'll see you in court